dont la région de Belgorod les attaques
ont laissé des traces les habitants
constatent les dégâts sur leur maison
une grande partie de la population a été
évacuée selon le gouverneur des attaques
de drones ont visé plusieurs maisons et
un bâtiment officiel dont la nuit de
lundi à mardi aucune victime n'est venu
s'ajouter au blessé de la veille
à propos de la situation dans le
district de driveron l'opération de
ratissage menée par le ministère de la
Défense et les forces de l'ordre se
poursuit je m'adresse aux habitants du
district qui ont quitté leurs immeubles
depuis un moment merci mais il est trop
tôt pour que vous reveniez
[Musique]
la Russie a décrété un régime
d'opérations antiterroriste dans cette
région de belgorodt frontalières de
l'Ukraine l'objectif repousser un groupe
de combattants que Moscou lit à l'armée
ukrainienne de son côté Kiev ni tout
implication l'opération a cependant été
revendiquée sur une chaîne telegram qui
se présente comme appartenant à un
groupe de Russes combattant côté
ukrainien
il est venu le temps de mettre fin à la
dictature du Kremlin merci beaucoup à
tous ceux qui nous soutiennent votre
soutien et ce qui nous rappelle chaque
jour notre objectif final sur la Place
Rouge
soyez courageux et n'ayez pas peur par
ce que nous revenons à la maison la
Russie sera libre
la Légion liberté pour la Russie avait
déjà revendiqué plusieurs incursions
dans la région de Belgorod ces dernières
semaines